el escenario es Modesto pero el fervor
es igual de importante
el público Está disfrutando del
espectáculo que es ciertamente
sangriento
esta muestra en el Estado de México
vecino de la capital aquí se permiten
las corridas de toros mientras que en la
Ciudad de México están prohibidas una
pena que que se tomen ese tipo de
decisiones porque es parte de nuestra
cultura es una convivencia que se da
entre el pueblo y entre familia va a
haber mucho desempleo ya que pues los
trabajadores todas las personas que
trabajan ahí es lamentable en ese
aspecto no es posible para los 9
millones de habitantes de la capital
asistir a un espectáculo taurino el 10
de junio un juez suspendió las corridas
de toros tras un recurso de la
asociación justicia justa Mariana Luis
Alvarado en participó en la redacción
del texto Nosotros tomamos en cuenta la
Constitución de la Ciudad de México que
Establece en su artículo 13 la
protección a los animales aquí estamos
hablando de una dignidad que se les
reconoce a los animales y cómo nosotros
como personas estamos obligados jurídica
y éticamente a darles digno a ello la
Plaza México la mayor plaza de toros del
mundo está ahora vacía
un duro golpe para su propietario y
torero retirado varios dulaika la
tauromaquia está permitida y este está
dentro de la Constitución está regulada
en dentro de los artículos dos de
celebración de espectáculos públicos
desde las corridas tienen un lugar
específico donde se celebran una hora
específica tú tienes que comprar un
boleto para entrar es libre la decisión
para poder asistir o no la batalla legal
entre los defensores y los detractores
de la taurmaquia está en curso el
recurso debe ser analizado en detalle
por los jueces de la Ciudad de México la
decisión final podría sentar un
precedente ya que cinco estados
mexicanos han embudo definitivamente las
corridas de toros